[Música]
la educación no cambia el mundo cambia
las personas que van a cambiar al mundo
maría montessori creía en un método en
el que el alumno participaba en su
proceso de aprendizaje donde era el
principal actor de su conocimiento el
cual descubría el mismo por medio de
experimentación
de niño
siempre estaba siguiendo las
instrucciones que mis maestros me daban
lo hacía como ellos decían todo al pie
de la letra
entonces cuando alrededor de mis seis
años perdí mi creatividad
llegué a pensar que necesitaba ser como
todos actuar como todos y seguir esta
serie de reglas la sociedad imponía para
de alguna manera ser parte de ella
pero todo esto cambió cuando años atrás
con los causales que significa unidad de
servicio de apoyo a la educación regular
usar me muestra un método que me permite
ser yo misma y hace que vuelva a
encontrarme
este método me deja hacer lo que yo
quiera y de la manera en que yo quiera
por ejemplo una vez leí un libro de
física cuántica para adolescentes donde
un joven viajaba por otra dimensión y
comenzaba a aprender sobre esta ciencia
que es la física y saben que fue
asombroso en ese entonces estaba en
segundo grado de secundaria entonces
llevaba lo que es la materia de física
logré empaparme toda esta fantasía que
el libro me presentaba y en consecuencia
puede obtener mejores calificaciones
[Música]
también conocí a bukowski appo y demás
gente maravillosa por medio de internet
después de eso comencé a escribir poesía
cuando mi entonces maestra de artes nos
lleva dos compañeras a mí a varias
exposiciones de pintura hay una
exposición que me marca y ese día cuando
vuelvo a casa tomo papel y pluma y
comienzo a escribir
y desde ese día no he dejado de hacerlo
usa el medio de vuelta a mi creatividad
como sabemos el mundo está en constante
cambio cada día a cada hora
pero la educación es la misma desde 1800
el siglo 19 en la segunda revolución
industrial también conocida como la
revolución tecnológica en el pasado los
empresarios necesitaban una clase de
hombre máquina para un trabajo rápido
entonces pensaron en un sistema dentro
de la educación que hiciera eso por
ellos un sistema que dijera que una
verdad era la única y es lo que había
pero entonces porque si el mundo está en
constante cambio la educación no tiene
cambios primero que es la educación
educación es un trabajo en equipo es
aprender en sociedad es conectar con
nosotros y lograr que los otros conecten
con nosotros
en robinson dice que perdemos la
creatividad a medida de que crecemos que
las escuelas matan la creatividad de los
estudiantes y que la creatividad es todo
este proceso de tener ideas que tienen
valor
y si entonces la inteligencia es
dinámica y es distinta y el ser humano
es creativo por naturaleza porque parece
que estamos empeñados en crear humanos
máquina dentro de las escuelas
imagina que tu maestro
logras conectar con tu alumno y logras
enseñarle a cuestionarse la vida
demuestra los retos la creatividad la
observación y el descubrimiento
aprendes a enseñar conversando y las
largas clases que involucraban
agotamiento físico y mental
se acaban
[Música]
aprendes a enseñar conversando
imaginad a un alumno que se encuentra a
sí mismo por medio de la
retroalimentación de jade sobre
saturarse de información que después
tendrá que escupir en una hoja para que
le dé una calificación y por primera vez
aprende de verdad
mi proyecto brinda a los maestros un
apoyo adicional dado por alumnos con el
mismo interés en la educación que el
miedo sería un valiente que levante la
mano por sus compañeros y busquen una
manera más dinámica de entender un tema
los alumnos trabajarían en colaboración
con los maestros en material designadas
por medio de intereses y habilidades
por ejemplo el semestre pasado en
matemáticas
estaba viendo lo que son determinantes
de triángulos y polígonos entonces
llegaba el maestro y comenzaba a
explicar cómo sacar las coordenadas para
después hacer una tabulación y al último
una ecuación que nos daría el área de
nuestro triángulo o polígono según fuera
el caso
y cuando terminaba la clase por mente no
pasaba más que hoy
ya está aprende cómo hacerlo pero y esto
de que me va a servir
pues qué tal si el maestro para
resolvernos esta duda nos saca lo que es
la explanada del plantel
nos dice que miramos los lados y que
comenzamos a graficar para después hacer
nuestra ecuación de determinantes para
encontrar nuestra área
aplicación en la vida cotidiana que nos
da conocimiento
o también en segundo semestre llevaba la
materia de química y a los últimos temas
eran sobre nomenclatura resolvería
compuestos de carbono y demás
al terminar la clase yo salía y
comenzaba asimilar toda esta teoría que
acababa de ver estaba comiendo algo y
decía esto es esto y tienes o también me
estaba peinando y utilizaban una crema
para el cabello y decía eso es esto
tiene esto funciona de esta manera en mi
organismo y de esta manera en el
ecosistema
después me di cuenta que no era la única
que me estaba volviendo loca
mi grupo de amigos también estaba
asimilando está teoría como yo lo hacía
y eso hacía que nos fuera mucho mejor en
los exámenes
comenzó a vivir una realidad en la que
podía ver mi vida cotidiana todo lo que
aprendía en clase
y esto me hizo interesarme por la
escuela ya no solo por un buen promedio
sino por el mero placer de aprender
tengo un maestro que nos dice que el día
que comencemos a interesarnos por las
cosas todo va a cambiar y tiene mucha
razón
porque recuerden que un joven que no es
revolucionario tiene una contradicción
hasta biológica
me encantaría
cualquier joven tuviera la oportunidad
de trabajar en conjunto vamos a ir así
como yo la tuve pero viéndolo
objetivamente hoy no es posible
me gusta pensar en crear uno sea que sea
para cualquier joven interesado en
aprender para cualquier joven interesado
en esta complicadísima ecuación llamada
vida
así que les propongo una educación que
motiva reflexiona y responsabiliza por
medio
de la experimentación propia y de esta
manera lo veremos una experimentación
que transforma
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]